hace un par de vídeos atrás empezamos a
aprender toda esta idea sobre la vida
media sobre la vida vida media
díaz y bueno nos dimos cuenta de que
somos buenos si tratamos de encontrar
cuánto del compuesto nos quedará después
de una vida media o dos vidas medias o
tres vidas medias es decir podemos tomar
la mitad del compuesto en cada uno de
los periodos ahora esto no es muy útil
cuando intentamos averiguar cuánto del
compuesto nos quedarán después de la
mitad de la vida media o después de un
día o 10 segundos o 10 billones de años
y para llegar a esto demostré en el
último vídeo la demostración que
envolvía un poquito de matemáticas
sofisticadas y bueno si no has tomado
cálculo te recomiendo que de una manera
sencilla te saltes este vídeo ahora si
eres una persona curiosa te puedo decir
que en ese vídeo fue cuando probamos la
siguiente fórmula la fórmula que dice me
lo voy a poner aquí que dado cualquier
en el tiempo si tú tienes un cierto
átomo radioactivo algún elemento
entonces la desintegración radioactiva
puede moderarse por la fórmula la
cantidad de elementos en que depende de
ti que depende del tiempo es decir en
cualquier punto en el tiempo es igual es
igual a la cantidad con la que empezaste
y esa le habíamos puesto el nombre de n
subíndice 0 en el subíndice 0 que
multiplica a el que multiplica a el
elevado a la menos camps y bueno en el
vídeo pasado le pusimos a esta constante
lambda pero como es una constante no
importa el nombre que tenga he elevado a
la menos que multiplica a su vez al
tiempo
esta era la fórmula que encontramos en
el vídeo pasado en que depende del
tiempo es igual a en el sub zero que
multiplica a elevado en la menos
catherine y bueno si ya tenemos esta
fórmula
datos de algún elemento particular y
además sabemos su vida media entonces
podemos calcular de una manera sencilla
el valor de acá y entonces aplicar el
otro problema así que con lo que vamos a
ver en este vídeo
algunas de estas constantes como acá o
como en el sub zero o como nm te
quedarán cada vez más claras pero bueno
qué te parece si hacemos un ejemplo el
carbono 14 y déjame cambiar de color el
carbono 14 vimos en el vídeo pasado que
tenía una vida media y lo voy a poner
aquí el carbono 14 el carbono 14 tiene
una vida media de 5.730
años es decir que si utilizamos esta
información
entonces la podemos aplicar en esta
fórmula la vida media lo que nos está
diciendo es que después de cinco mil
setecientos treinta años va a quedar la
mitad de la cantidad inicial con la que
empezamos y por lo tanto y déjame
ponerlo así con otro color por lo tanto
si yo me fijo en n en n de 5.730 años
bueno pues esto aplicando la fórmula en
primer lugar es exactamente lo mismo que
en esos 0 que en el subíndice es 0 lo
que quiere decir la cantidad con la que
empezamos esto que a su vez multiplica a
ok
elevado a la menos que a la menos k por
el tiempo pero el tiempo son cinco mil
setecientos treinta años cinco mil
setecientos treinta años así que lo voy
a poner aquí ya que multiplica a cinco
mil 703
años y bueno nosotros sabemos que como
es la vida media entonces esto es
exactamente igual a pues la mitad de la
cantidad con la que empezamos es decir
en el subíndice 0 esto dividido entre 2
la mitad de la cantidad con la que
empezamos y bueno ahora sí de aquí
queremos despejar acá entonces qué te
parece si en un primer lugar dividimos
todo entre en el subíndice 0 y éste es
raíz y éste es raíz y entonces voy a
quedarme con que el elevado a la menos
5.730 acá lo único que estoy haciendo es
volteando estos dos esto es lo mismo que
un medio y ahora si me quiero tomar el
lugar y tmo natural de ambos lados tomó
el lugar y no natural de esto que tengo
aquí ok y tomó el lugar ismo natural de
este que tengo aquí entonces que me va a
quedar ahora recuerda que si tomamos el
logaritmo natural de ambos lados del
lado izquierdo que quedan bueno pues
ahora qué
que cuando tomemos el logaritmo natural
de elevado a lo que sea es ese lo que
sea lo que me queda es decir lugar
natural de elevado la am es simplemente
a así que de aquí lo único que me va a
quedar es menos 5.730 camps así que tan
déjame ponerlo aquí menos 5.730 que
multiplica acá esto es exactamente lo
mismo que el logaritmo natural de un
médium y ya casi tenemos el valor de acá
para obtener el valor de acá lo único
que hay que hacer de kim es dividir todo
entre menos 5.730 y me va a quedar que
camps es exactamente lo mismo que el
logaritmo natural de un medio esto
dividido entre menos 5.700
ok y bueno justo en el vídeo pasado
hicimos esta operación que tenemos aquí
pero de todas maneras lo voy a hacer en
este vídeo así que déjame traer por acá
mi calculadora vamos a traerlo por acá y
ahora lo que quiero calcular es el
logaritmo natural ok de punto 5 ok
punto 5 es un medio y esto lo voy a
dividir ok entre menos donde estén menos
menos 5.730 de lujo y esto es
exactamente lo mismo que ok 0.0001 2 os
lo puedo poner como a 1.2 por 10 a la
decoró 1-2-3-4 por 10 al menos 4 así que
mejor lo voy a poner justo así esto es
exactamente lo mismo que 1.2
por 10 al menos 4 ok y ya con esto estoy
sacando el valor de camps y eso me va a
servir bastante porque entonces ya tengo
la expresión de la fórmula general para
el carbono 14 y es más si ahora utilizo
este color
y yo pongo n dt y sigo hablando del
carbono 14 así que déjenme ponerle que
esto es para el carbono 14 ok si
quisiéramos sacar la fórmula general
para otro elemento entonces a rectificar
nos en la vida media de ese elemento
para así poder obtener el valor de la
constante k entonces esto es exactamente
igual a en el subíndice 0 y en el
subíndice 0 que multiplica a la
exponencial elevado a la menos camps
pero ya sabemos el valor de camps es
justo este que tenemos aquí 1.2 por 10
al menos 4 es decir el elevado a la
menos 1.2
10 elevado a menos 4 y todo esto hay que
multiplicarlo por el tiempo todo esto lo
multiplicamos por el tiempo que es justo
este dato que me dan y bueno ya que
tenemos aquí esta fórmula esta expresión
de kim que te parece si la utilizamos
para resolver un problema vamos a decir
que y déjame bajar un poco la pantalla
porque ya no tengo espacio por aquí y
qué te parece si ahora decimos que
empezamos con 300 gramos de carbono 14
así que voy a decir que mi cantidad
inicial de carbono 14 son 300 gramos
tengo 300 gramos ok de carbono 14 ok y
yo lo que quiero saber es cuánto me va a
quedar de estos 300 gramos de carbono 14
y después de 2000 años así que déjame
aquí lo que quiero saber es qué es lo
que va a quedar después de eso
de de 2000 años
años de lujo y bueno lo único que hay
que hacer es enchufar estos datos en
esta ecuación que tenemos aquí y
entonces me va a quedar lo siguiente que
n que n de dos mil años
nd y aquí voy a poner dos mil n de dos
mil años ok esto a quien va a ser igual
bueno esto va a ser igual a la cantidad
inicial pero la cantidad inicial la
sabemos son 300 gramos 300 ok que
multiplica
déjeme poner lo cual este color que
multiplica a elevado a la menos 1.2 por
10 a la menos cuatro por el tiempo que
es esto entonces lo voy a poner así
1.21.2
10 al menos 4 y esto a su vez está
multiplicando a 2000 años entonces esto
por 2000 y bueno es hora para obtener la
solución de este problema de sacar de
nuevo la calculadora así que la voy a
traer por acá ya la tengo aquí y lo que
tengo que hacer es 300 x
todo esto de aquí entonces vamos a
ponerlo 300 ok que multiplican que
multiplica a m elevado elevado a la
potencia a la potencia 1.2 por 10 en la
menos 4 que es justo lo que tenemos aquí
arriba entonces a la potencia menos la
respuesta anterior ok que esto
multiplica a 2000 a 2000 ok
cierro paréntesis y lo hago con mucho
cuidado voy a obtener la respuesta y la
respuesta es 235 puntos 53 gramos 235
así que lo voy a poner justo aquí lo que
va a quedar
de 2000 años es 235 gramos de lujo así
de fácil y así de sencillo esto está
genial usando esta fórmula la fórmula
del decaimiento exponencial podemos
obtener la cantidad de carbono 14 que
tendremos después de cualquier periodo
de tiempo en un período de tiempo que no
forzosamente sea la vida media y bueno
como esto está tan genial vamos a hacer
otro más otro problema muy parecido a
este se me ocurre ahora a tomarnos en un
inicio 400 gramos de carbono 14 y
déjenme bajar un poco más la pantalla
bajemos un poco más la pantalla a esta
fórmula me va a servir entonces vamos a
empezar esta vez con 400 gramos de
carbono 14 con 400 gramos de carbono 14
esto en un inicio es mi cantidad inicial
ya
lo que quiero saber es en qué tiempo es
decir mi incógnita esta vez será el
tiempo en qué tiempo voy a obtener una
cantidad de 350 gramos de carbono 14
es decir en cuánto tiempo en cuánto
tiempo el tiempo es lo que no sé ok se
convierten en 350 gramos y déjame
ponerlo con este otro color los voy a
convertir en 350 gramos después de un
cierto tiempo y bueno entonces vamos a
poner los datos que nosotros tenemos en
esta ecuación general para el carbono 14
entonces a y déjeme escribirlo por aquí
si yo lo que quiero es el tiempo
entonces sé la cantidad que me va a
quedar que son 350 gramos y sustituyendo
aquí me va a quedar que 350 gramos esto
va a ser igual es decir la cantidad con
la que voy a finalizar es exactamente lo
mismo que la cantidad inicial
con 400 gramos 400 gramos ok que
multiplican que multiplican a m que
multiplica ha elevado a la menos camps
pero acá vale 1.2 por 10 a la menos 4
así que lo voy a poner si 1.2 por am 10
al menos 4 ya esto lo voy a multiplicar
por el tiempo a esto lo voy a
multiplicar por el tiempo ok y justo lo
que quiero saber es el tiempo así que
vamos a despejar lo lo primero que se me
ocurre hacer es dividir todo entre 400
entonces éste se va a ir y de este lado
me va a quedar 350 entre 400 cuánto es
350 entre 400 es lo mismo que siete
octavos haber 350 entre 400 ok esto es
lo mismo que 0.8 175 aquí me va a quedar
0.8 175 es lo mismo que
elevado a la menos 1.2 por 10 de la
menos 40 déjame ponerlo así menos 1.2
por 10 al menos 4 ok
y ahora lo que voy a hacer es tomar el
logaritmo natural de ambos lados el
logaritmo natural de stem y el logaritmo
natural de todo esto que tengo aquí
ahora lo bueno es que sabemos que de
este lado derecho el logaritmo natural y
la exponencial cuando me toma el
logaritmo natural de elevado a lo que
sea me va a quedar solamente lo que sea
y entonces ante aquí voy a obtener y
déjame ponerlo así que el logaritmo
natural de 0.8 175 esto es exactamente
igual que 1.2 por 10 de la menos cuatro
de al menos 1.2
10 al menos 40 ok y lo que quiero es el
tiempo por lo tanto voy a dividir todo
entre menos 1.2 por 10 era menos 4
y déjame de una vez atrapar esto lo voy
a atrapar ok
lo voy a copiar lo voy a pegar ok
entonces este me va a servir porque voy
a dividir todo entre esto voy a dividir
todo entre esto ok a esta parte también
ok y entonces me va a quedar lo
siguiente am y déjeme ver esto me va a
quedar como una división esto también
pero estos dos se van este y éste se van
y solamente me queda el tiempo es decir
que lo que busco el tiempo es
exactamente igual a esta expresión que
tengo aquí y para eso vamos a sacar de
nuevo mi calculadora y vamos a hacer las
respectivas cuentas que tengo aquí tengo
el logaritmo natural de
0.8 175 ok a esto lo voy a dividir entre
am - 1.21.2 por 10 a la menos 4 así que
voy a traer por acá el por 10 aunque a
esto lo voy a multiplicar por 10 elevado
a la menos 4 todo esto con paréntesis
todo esto con paréntesis y esto va a ser
igual a mil 112 años de lujo ya tenemos
la solución de este problema esto es lo
mismo que en mil 112 años
niños y de lujo ya tengo la solución de
este problema y tal vez esto se ve un
poquito complicado pero realmente lo
único que tienes que hacer es recordar
dejar de subir un poco en la pantalla
recordar esta fórmula que tenemos aquí
esta es la fórmula más importante de
todo lo que hemos trabajado esta que
tenemos aquí
esta de aquí y si lo que quieres saber
es de dónde salió esta fórmula tienes
que ver el vídeo pasado y bueno para
cualquier elemento en particular primero
debes resolver esta fórmula para obtener
el valor de campo de la vida media y
después solo debes de sustituir lo que
sabes para obtener lo que no sabes
utilizando esta fórmula de aquí y de
lujo en el siguiente vídeo voy a
trabajar con otros problemas parecidos